Miami. Alec is an actress,
writer and neuroscientist.
Her official bio says that she's best
known as Amy Farrah Fowler on the Big Bang
theory. But I hope it's okay if I say
that for some of us it's blossom. Yes.
I'm obviously the blossom demographic.
Oh, I appreciate that. Um,
she is the author of beyond the sling
and Mimes Vegan table and her latest book
is girling up.
Please welcome my and Galic.
Thank you so much for joining us.
Thanks for having me. Horse. Um,
so to start things off,
the book is called girling up.
And the subtitle of the book is how
to be strong, smart, and spectacular.
Why those three qualities?
So the book is, um, is
written for girls 10 to 18,
and anyone who ever was a girl tend
to 18 or knows a girl 10 to 18.
Um, and we, we wanted a subtitle
cause it's fun to have one,
you know, and um, there's a
reason that it's not, you know,
how to be saucy, Sassy and sexy.
Um, the, the qualities that,
that I'm trying to support
and give a voice to or those,
you know,
of strength and intelligence and you know,
sort of m and a whimsical,
eccentric notion of being spectacular,
which can be different things
for different girls. Um,
but also kind of, you know,
to speak to that as well. When we first
saw ideas for, for covers, you know,
they kind of wanted to do like, like, Ooh,
here's my, I'm thinking, you know, like,
like pretty headshot with
glasses and you know, um, those,
those were lovely photos.
But, um, I really said no,
I want it to look like
more my personality.
Like I want to be in a cape and
converse like, so there you go.
I'm in a cave with converse
and um, yeah, I mean,
we really wanted it to feel not
like a feminine, but you know,
I specifically said like,
it doesn't have to be pink.
There's nothing biological about females
that makes us want the color pink.
I actually never liked the color pink and
still don't. So, um, I, I like that it's,
it's kind of bold and it's quirky.
And you know, we have some,
some sciency symbols and um,
yeah,
it kind of feels appropriate for strength
and smartness and spectacularness.
Yeah.
What inspired you to write a book for
girls and people who know them and have
been them? Um, you know,
it's funny because the three
books that I have written,
I was not inspired to write them.
I was, um, I was approached and,
and um, this isn't just like people,
you know, being nice to celebrities.
Like can you should write a book. Like
I was specifically approached, like,
will you write this book? And I've
been asked to put my face on, um,
several books. Um, I don't want many,
several, I don't know my book agents here,
so I can't lie. Um, but I
have enough books of like,
will you be the face of this science
book for Girls? And you know,
it didn't really feel right because
science is super broad and um, you know,
I know how people feel
about celebrity books.
I totally do because I feel that way too.
You know, like did they really write it?
Is it authentic? Like, is it really
going to be meaningful? And, um,
this book came about because,
so I have a website called Grok nation
and I write essays about all sorts of
things.
And one of the things I wrote about was
there was an episode of Big Bang Theory
where Sheldon and Amy have
coitus for the first time.
And I wrote an article
about what it was like to,
to not only play a late
bloomer on television,
but to be a late bloomer in
real life and how, you know,
both Jim and I kind of felt
like, gosh, this is a really
intimate moment, you know,
that we're sharing with potentially
millions of people. And I just wrote,
you know, kind of a thoughtful
nerdy essay about, um, you know,
some of that conflict of boundaries and
where my intimate brain ends and where
this character's begins. And Jill
Santa's Polo, who's an editor at Penguin,
reached out to me and she said, I saw
your article and Grok nation and I would,
I would like you to write a book with
this kind of voice that has an ocean of
modesty without being religious or
political. Um, and I said, well,
that's very kind, but, um, can we do more?
And so I took my inspiration
actually from Madeley Angier,
who's a science writer
for the New York Times.
And she wrote a book called woman and
intimate geography. And what it was,
was actually a kind of cross species
comparison of how other mammals and other
animals do things versus how women do.
But it really was a full geography of
being a woman. And so I said to Jill,
what if I basically did a version of
that about the full female experience?
And instead of using
other species as examples,
I use other cultures and a lot of places.
And because I'm trained as a scientist,
I kind of go from,
you know,
chromosomes and hormones through sex
and dating to how our brains learn,
how our bodies get fed and nurtured.
Um,
and because it is a book
in the 21st century, how we
deal with difficult things.
Um, mental health issues,
eating disorders, depression,
um, abuse, things like that.
Uh, and then the final chapter is like
how we make a difference in the world and
encouraging young girls, um, to, to
think in an age appropriate way. Um,
no one ever told me to do any of these
things is also really why I decided that
I should write this book.
My mom didn't really talk to me about
any of this stuff. Um, body stuff,
anything like that.
My mom came from a very conservative
religious household and um, yeah,
just these things weren't talked about
and I wished someone had talked to me
about all of these things.
So I wrote a book so that other
girls can hear about these things.
Yeah. And, and like you said, it
does, it covers a ton. Yeah. I,
I'm curious now you said no one's really,
no one ever really talked to you
about this stuff when you were a kid.
If you could give this book
to like 12 year old Miami,
what chapter would you point her to first?
Um, well, you know, there's a reason I put
the chapters in the order that I did. Um,
you know, I think starting
with chapter one is a good
place, but, you know, there's,
there's a lot or I guess was a
lot in their most, oh, what did,
what did she need most?
Uh,
it feels like it's something my
therapist would ask me. Sorry,
what 12 year old Maya I'm needed most.
Um,
honestly I think that the
chapter about intimacy,
which obviously include sex and dating,
which I was not ready to think
about even at 16 or 17. Uh,
but some of the stuff about sort of the
way that we form intimate relationships
with other people even that are not
romantic would have been helpful. Um,
you know, I included a section about how
to tell if someone is not a good friend.
Yeah.
And literally no one ever said that to me.
It was just like I'd come home crying
and like she said this about me and my
mother would be like, I don't know
what to do. Don't be friends with them,
you know?
And so it really like,
it occurred to me what if
we lay out guidelines for
how people should treat each
other, you know, and the
expectations you can have.
And of course it's not always going
to be like that. And I'm like,
I already was the kid who, you know,
talk like a grownup when I was 12.
It didn't make me very
popular. Um, but, but no,
I think that that chapter ultimately
would have been very helpful in,
in terms of all kinds of, um, you
know, intimacy, because intimacy is,
those are the relationships we have
with our family and with our friends.
It's not just the scary ones. Yeah. Sorry.
Still even thinking of them as the scan.
Yeah, exactly. Yeah. I'm 41
and it's still scary. Yeah.
You, uh, you know, talking about, um,
the,
the fact that when you were 12,
you were already sort of
talking like an adult, an adult.
What was it like writing a book with
all of this really big subject matter,
including, you know, science and
psychology and all of this stuff.
Aiming it at children.
Yeah. I should also point out, um,
I'd like to apologize to my publicist,
Heather bezerk.
Oh,
I forgot to take the bandaids off
my pinky toes and they are showing.
So I wouldn't want anyone to look and say
like, Haha, mine was wearing bandaids.
I was wearing very high, high heels before
and my toes were hurting. And Heather,
I'll take off the bat how to
wear high heels or something.
I understand like there are
bandaids on my pinky does. Um,
but I didn't want someone to think
she doesn't know there's bandage.
I know it's real. It's real life.
It's, this is totally worth, yeah.
Very real right now. Um, how did it
feel? It was difficult. You know,
I'm a person who loves words.
I love language.
I remember many s a t words
and use them often. And, uh,
I really had to write a book without
my full vocabulary, you know,
I was allowed to use or I was,
I needed to use by full intellectual
and emotional vocabulary,
but I had to do it with
words that, um, yeah,
that would make sense for a 10 to 18 year
old audience. And, um, and in addition,
you know,
you can't just say that things are great
over and over because you can't use all
of your other adjectives that can't
be like, you know, everything's great,
the brain's great, you know,
hormones are great. Like, you know,
you have to find other
ways to explain things.
My 11 year old son was my first
kind of proper proofreader and, uh,
he didn't like chapter one at all because
there are a lot of diagrams of the
woman's body. He wasn't
interested in that at all. Uh,
so that was not his favorite
chapter. But, um, you know,
I really want to just to know from him,
like, does it flow? Is it interesting?
Do I sound like a scolding mom? And
he's like, you are a scolding mom.
But objectively speaking,
he said, um, you know,
it felt right to him and there were
things that were interesting. Um,
not those diagrams. Right?
Yeah. Right. And you have, you
have two sons, right? Yeah.
Eight and 11.
Those aren't their names,
although many Hollywood people name
their children, things like that.
Can you talk a little bit about the,
the decision to write a book for
girls while you have sons? Are there,
I'm not saying like, why didn't you write
it up for your own? Believe me, I've,
I've been out, I'm not, I'm
more interested in just,
you know, raising sons.
There are also conversations that you
must have to have with them about girls
and their own bodies.
Sure. Growing up as boys,
I'm just curious how you've
been thinking about that. I've,
I've gotten,
I've gotten this question asked in many
productive ways and several unproductive
ways, um, you know, and,
and in the world of social media,
you see all sorts of questions.
Like literally,
why would you write a book for girls?
Why not for boys to which
I respond? Well, I did,
I responded to that comment. Um, you know,
or what gives you the authority? I said,
well, I'm a female. I, you know,
that's like, that's where we'll start.
I was a girl and now I'm
a woman. Um, I chose to,
to write this book largely because of,
you know,
Jill approaching me about
kind the specific voice
about being a female and the
fact that I grew up in the limelight,
you know,
I was on blossom from the time I was 14
to 19 and I started acting when I was 11.
So, you know, I, I grew up in
some very critical years, um,
really in the public eye.
And although standards for women were
different then and there wasn't social
media and there wasn't,
you know, kind of the,
the publicity machine directed
around women in particular,
I think that puts a lot of pressure on us.
Um, I definitely had a notion of being,
you know, on display, you know,
as a woman in a culture that I
don't always find friendly to women.
So that I think was, you know, kind
of part of the perspective that I,
that I wanted to bring to
girling up. And, you know,
the fact is I dedicated this book
to my boys because you don't really,
everything I do is as their mother and
they will meet women in their lives who,
you know,
hopefully if they haven't read this book
will have read other books that empower
them and make them
believe in the values of,
of knowing more about yourself and making
an impact in the world. And, you know,
people get very, um, certain
people get very uppity, you know,
when they hear that I'm a feminist or
that I'm raising feminist children,
you know, and um, you know, I'm, I'm
not a person who hates men actually.
I quite like men. And,
um, I, I'm not raising my,
my boys to be afraid of masculinity.
I mean,
I think a lot of people just literally
don't know the definition that, you know,
feminism is a,
is a movement that believes in a unique
role of women to break the bonds of race,
class and gender. And, um, my sons
understand that. And, um, there,
there is information in this book about
boys' bodies as well as girls bodies and
much of what is in this book applies
to males as well as females. So yeah,
I speak to my children about hormones.
Um,
they know about gender fluidity because
they hear it in the news and, uh,
they just, you know, we just used to
call it like Mama's boyish, you know,
like why does Mama likes sports cars
and data doesn't, you know, data lakes,
musical theater just cause, you
know, cause everybody's different.
So they've already had a lot of these
conversations. But, you know, I think,
I think it's okay for us to acknowledge
that, you know, for most of human history,
women have been excluded from
a lot of the workplace, um,
and have been denied a lot
of the rights that men had.
And it's okay to say that we
want to have this kind of book.
There are books for boys,
there will continue to be books for boys.
Men have written most of the
books in human history. Uh,
if you kind of look at like a bell
curve of it, you know, um, and,
and I really feel like it's totally
okay to also acknowledge that, you know,
the male body is very different than the
female body and the fact that, you know,
the male genitalia is on the outside
is a lot more informative than women's
bodies where everything
is, you know, protected.
And so there's a lot to know about
what's going on in there and as well of
course there are exceptions to all of
these things, but women are, you know,
a very verbal and social creature and
there's a lot that we're not encouraged to
kind of talk about and bring out. And I
think men are seeing that too. You know,
men can be emotional and we need to
talk about all those things, but I also,
you know, I don't feel like one should
have to defend, you know, a special book,
um, for girls. Yeah. I feel
like we're in a safe place here.
I feel like not being attacked yet yet,
yet.
Just turn the page questions. Um, so you,
you know, you have, you've
written three books,
you write essays and articles and all
sorts of stuff and you're very outspoken
as we've just seen with your,
oh, that was like a warm up.
Um, I actually, I read in
another interview with you
that you were saying that,
you know, growing up Jewish, you were
like raised in an argumentative tradition.
I was like, yes, yes. I feel that
I'll, if I want to get fancy,
you can call it like the
dialectic tradition, but you know,
that's only in philosophy class. So they
call us like being Jewish, right? Yeah.
When you're out to dinner with your family
over there. Right, exactly. Yeah. Um,
but you do, you have a very strong
and specific worldview and you know,
you live that in your, all of your
life choices, everything's fine. Okay.
Okay. Um, you know, the,
your Jewish faith and being
vegan and all of this stuff.
And I'm curious how you approached
writing a book that would be inviting and
accessible and helpful to girls from a
wide range of backgrounds and have their
own beliefs and their family's beliefs
while still being true to your own.
Yeah, I mean, this is a great question
because it's a great challenge, you know,
when, when writing this kind of thing,
especially because, you know, I was,
I was approached really because Jill,
you know, this editor at Penguin,
because Jill really liked
this voice that I had,
which is really one of
social conservatism,
which you can be socially conservative
even if you're a bleeding heart liberal.
I promise. It's like, here
I am. Um, but, um, you know,
I wanted to make sure that it didn't
feel like a part is in book. You know,
I happen to believe in,
in a certain kind of,
of politics and I happen to believe
in a certain religious tradition.
And you know, one of the ways that I
talk about that historically people cope,
you know, in the chapter on how we
cope is by you know, structured,
organized activities,
some of which are religious in nature.
But I really tried to kind of at
every turn I'm saying, you know,
even if this doesn't work for you,
here are some of the advantages of people
congregating regularly in a community
setting. Um, just to again,
sort of give information that can then
be used to make decisions. And I think,
you know, a lot of times you get
knee jerk reactions or you know,
I responded in a knee jerk fashion
really for much of these years.
So I think being presented lots of
different options is healthy and also
presenting information in a way that
there are many options is helpful. Um,
but for me, you know, in the,
in the chapter on, you know,
basically in nutrition and what we eat
and how our body is fueled by that.
I do talk about my, my personal
choices. Yes, I happen to be Vegan,
but I make it really clear
and it's really true.
I know that being Vegan is
not for everyone. You know,
we all know that every major medical
organization says we all should eat less
processed foods and less meat and
less animal byproducts. Um, but,
but I didn't want that to
be an agenda of the book.
And I wrote a Vegan cookbook for God's
sake. Like if you want an agenda book,
like that's it, you know.
Um, but I do think, you know,
it's also important, you know,
to look at all,
all aspects of these kinds of angles.
And I did talk about how
many young girls and yes,
some young boys as well, but
many young girls, um, are, uh,
adopting a vegetarian or Vegan
diet as a way to lose weight.
And that's actually not, you
know, the purpose. I mean, yes,
some people do tend to lose weight.
It's,
you can also gain weight as
a vegetarian or a Vegan. Um,
but I made sure to also point to some
of the larger issues because you know,
those,
again,
those are things that weren't really
talked about and it is important for us to
talk about them. And it's, you know, the
kind of thing that feels Yucky, you know,
when you hear of, you know, a friend's
daughter or a niece or whatever who,
you know, is having eating
problems and it's being couched in,
in eating preferences.
Those are complicated things.
But I really think it's healthy to get
it out there. I hope that it is. Yeah.
And it's, it's so tricky to talk
about because on the one hand,
any kind of restrictive eating can be
a signal of something raised kosher.
So it's like, you know, we have thousands
of years of restrictions, but I,
for like when a young girl
starts taking that on,
it's tied in with all this other sort
of baggage, but it can also, you know,
I know people who've started eating
vegetarian or Vegan for health or sort of
vague restrictive reasons
and then along the way,
like discover other reasons and sort of
like pack on that I suppose as you go.
Yeah, that was kind of, that was my story
as well, so, yeah. But, um, back to the,
I guess the sort of the conservatism
can be the idea of being sort of
conservative while also
bleeding heart liberal. The,
you mentioned modesty earlier and one of
the things that really intrigued me in
the book actually was your mention of
modesty in the acknowledgements. Um,
you think two women who I think
are both rabbis, right? Uh,
remind me I didn't write their names down.
Shall lead.
When does she'll eat, wrote a return
to modesty. It was drag knowledge. Her,
hold on, hold on. This is fun. Tell us
who she is while I look this up. Uh,
well when he shall lead, uh, is an
author who wrote, returned to modesty.
She's not a rabbi, but she wrote
a book about sort of the, the,
the reclaiming that a lot of women are
doing, um, not necessarily in a, you know,
in a religious manner.
Um,
but to reclaim the notions of having
choices about what they wear and how they
were, did you find it? I did find it.
So I think you mentioned as
mentioned in the chapter.
So here it was Aviva Colon, Alison
Joseph's. Both of whom are not rabbis.
This is why I wasn't sounding familiar.
Um, yeah, Alison Joseph's is a,
is an online presence. She goes by
June the city. She was actually,
I met her through partners in Torah,
which is a free organization that sets
you up with someone who can teach you
really anything you want to know about
Judaism. And one of the main things that,
and she's literally, I mean, I
don't want to say she's just a mom,
but she's not a a Jewish educational
professional. At that time,
she and I were both new moms.
Um,
she ended up kind of developing
an online presence and website,
educating people about modern
orthodoxy. Um, but anyway,
so that's who Alison Joseph says.
And one of the things we studied through
partners in Torah was modesty and why
Jewish women have rules and what the
rules are for Jewish men of Eva coal is a
[inaudible], which means
she's married to a rabbi. Um,
and she was the woman awkward.
She was the woman that I studied
with before I got married.
So in traditional Jewish weddings,
um, this may sound strange. Um,
women typically study,
uh,
things about being married with women.
And men typically study things
about being married with men.
And if you've ever heard of a
Mikvah, which is a ritual bath, um,
that is a spiritual and a
legal place that you immerse,
think of like a really holy
Jacuzzi. It's like that. Um,
I studied all of the rules. There are,
you know, thousands of years of tradition,
um, surrounding the use of
that ritual and tradition.
And it was something I've written
about very publicly, um, because I,
I found it very, um, very, um,
comforting to have that as a, as
a monthly ritual. Typically, um,
Jewish women go after their
menstrual cycle ends. Um,
and it is a not because we're dirty
or horrible, which is, you know,
what a lot of people assume, but I
found it very empowering and you know,
I do identify as a feminist who is part
of the structure of patriarchy, you know,
in that I am part of a, a Jewish
tradition, which is, you know,
patriarchal in its origins. Um, but
yeah, that was a lot cause everyone,
okay. Like, I may have hurt someone. Okay.
So then you're like, what
do I ask next? I was just,
I,
I'm going to continue the question
cause I'm sorry. That's it.
I still have the question, which was,
um, you, so what you write and yes,
this is what it's like to date me.
This is literally this problem and
what just happened is what it's like.
It's not a problem. Okay.
Thank you. Are we dating?
So the two women, I think two women
you think and you write that they, um,
they taught me the ways of decorum,
modesty and grace in the ancient
origins of these gifts have increased my
concept of worth dignity and the
divine ability to love and be loved.
I thought that was so lovely. It was
kind of lovely. I forgot that I wrote,
can you talk a little bit
about what that means?
Ah, I think that, um, you know,
you pick like one of the
most intimate thank you.
Besides my ex boyfriend and my ex husband
who are also thanked in there. Um, yeah,
I think that for me, um, you know,
I came late to observance. Um,
I was not raised religious.
My mother was raised Orthodox and
very, very, I'm kind of old world.
Her parents were immigrants.
She didn't speak English and her home,
they only spoke Yiddish. So, um,
she kind of raised me reform,
um, meaning she didn't want
a lot of ritual. And, um,
when I was in college,
I took on more observance.
And one of the things that
was very empowering for me
was to meet women who did
not feel oppressed.
Um,
and also women who didn't simply say like,
I'm part of the patriarchy,
therefore I don't feel oppressed. These
were intelligent college educated women,
which you don't have to be
going to college to be educated,
but you know what I mean? This wasn't the
stereotype of like, the woman who went,
you know, got married at 17 and
never saw the outside world.
These are women who had lived
in an integrated society, um,
and who were gorgeous,
um,
felt empowered in how
they presented themselves.
And I'm not going to pretend that there
are many women who want to be modest and
still be attractive. Um, honestly,
Alison dresses in clothing that I would
feel uncomfortable in because it's too
tight, but it's very, you know,
for her it's very modest than
it is modest by most standards.
But to meet women who had
fulfilling lives as women,
again within this kind of religious
structure was very comforting.
And I found that the rules
of, um, you know, uh,
it's, it's there, it's called
family purity. It sounds
better in Hebrew, I promise.
Um, but I found that the,
the rules governing, um,
marriage and love and intimacy really
protected something that I believe is very
sacred. And even though I'm divorced,
you know, I think that my, Mike,
I think that my, my ex would agree,
like, um, there was a lot of,
there were a lot of healthy boundaries,
you know, in our relationship.
And you know, when I think
about, you know, when I got
pregnant, it was, you know,
after visiting a spiritual ritual bath
where I had like a mystical, you know,
experience of this notion of
you can be reborn, you know, by,
by immersing and having this
experience, um, that's really, you know,
that's pleasant and it's bitter sweet.
I don't do that anymore
because not married. Um,
there are people who go to the ritual
bath, um, in other non traditional ways,
but for the kind of
traditional person that I am,
it really felt like something sacred
in, in the context of my marriage. Um,
and I credit those women with really
helping me find beauty in something that a
lot of people consider just,
you know,
kind of a knee jerk reaction like
that sexist. That's awful. Um,
and I also feel like
there's so many things,
not only in religion but in life as well.
You know,
that it's easy to sort of dismiss
like that. But, um, you know,
I chose to make a commitment
to get educated about it.
And for me it was very rewarding. I know
not everyone would have that experience.
And that's fine too.
Um, we're going to open it
up for questions in a minute.
So if you have a question, please stand
by one of the microphones in the aisle.
Um, but before we go to that, so the,
the book gives a lot of advice to
girls, suggestions, suggestions,
some framework, some guidelines
if you want some ideas. Um,
are there any suggestions
then that you would,
since you've spent so much time sort of
getting into the minds of girls between
10 and 18 and thinking about
what they're going through,
are there any suggestions that you
would offer to the parents of girls?
Don't let your children have phones
or leave the house. Does that work?
That's kind of what to know. Light does it
to know, I know that it doesn't. Um, no,
I think that, well, I know that,
you know, for me as a parent,
I think whether I had boys or had
girls, I do put a lot. And so,
so does my ax. We do put a lot of, um,
structure and boundaries around the kind
of information are children have access
to and, um, what, what and, and
knowing what they're doing. And for us,
um, for us that's comforting.
I think that a lot of parents,
especially parents who are younger than
I am, you know, cause I, I could easily,
well I'm 41 so do the math,
you know,
I could easily easily have a 20
year old or older. Um, you know,
I think a lot of parents in that
sort of middle generation, um,
are sometimes nervous to, to not be
friendly or be friends with their kid.
And I think there's a lot of benefit to
that, you know, and you know, I sort of,
I was raised in like a,
you know,
I was raised in a house where I
didn't have a lot of voice. Um, um,
because that's how people raise children
back then. So I think that there's,
there's something in between that I would
hope people find. But that being said,
I think it's okay to say no,
and I think it's okay to say,
um, yeah, you're, you're not ready
for a phone, which, you know,
my 11 year old is stomping his
foot every other day at us. Um,
but I do think it's okay to
say, I need your passwords. Um,
what are you doing on the computer?
What are you watching? Uh, and,
and I also think we shouldn't
be afraid to upset children. Um,
because a lot of times I think I,
I'm sometimes afraid to make decisions
because I'm afraid, you know,
that they'll feel controlled or
there'll be mad at me, you know. Um,
but I think it's very important
for parents to know that.
I hope that this book will kind of open
up conversations in terms of TV time and
screen time and things like that.
Um,
and in terms of like the
sex and dating chapter,
like that's going to really vary by kid.
You know,
I wasn't ready to learn that kind of
information until much later on that,
you know. Yeah. All right.
We have a question over here.
Hi. Um, a couple of years ago,
I read an article about pedophilia
culture and it talks about, um,
things like resilient waxes
and calling women girls.
And at that time I made the choice,
I am no longer going to call women girls
and maybe that shows a couple of years
ago and it's, it's always this
conscious effort. And, um,
I've gotten comfortable with it myself
and I've gotten comfortable correcting
someone when they refer to me as a girl,
you know, Google girl, Bianca, you know,
and I could get that. I'm like,
no Google woman. Um, but what,
I'm not making an alliteration issue.
I defend your right to correct,
not yet comfortable doing is correcting
that people when they refer to other
women as girls. And so you just posted a
video much more fun on, on social media,
which I really, really appreciated. Um,
and I hear this happening all the time.
I hear my colleagues referring
to other Google women as girls.
I hear them referring to clients
or agency partners as girls.
And it bugs me, but I don't, I
don't know how to address it.
And so I have been saying nothing and I
would like to say something and I would
like your thoughts on how to address it.
Um,
I didn't know where you were
going to go with that question.
That I am much more relaxed right
now than it was 30 seconds ago.
Um, so uh, Bianca was that your name?
Yes. What beyond cause referring to um,
his eye. So I make youtube
videos and um, you know, there's,
there's not necessarily a rhyme or
reason as to why something goes viral,
but we did have a video go
viral for the first time.
I think it has 9.6 million
views or something.
And it was about why we
shouldn't call women girls. Um,
then I released science and religion
about sort of my lack of conflict they're
in and that went viral the next week.
We had like a big month, you know,
it was a very big month.
So it's funny because this is something
I've been ranting about since I'm like
14 years old. Like this is just something
that's always really bothered me.
And the video was originally
longer cause I got, believe me,
I got a lot of comments if, why didn't
you talk about this? What about this?
You know,
what about the south in Tennessee,
there's a region where men are
called boys and like why, you know,
like all these like specific anecdotal
exceptions that prove that I'm a horrible
person. So anyway, but, um,
there are originally was,
um, a part of that video that
talked about exceptions, um, in, in,
in intimate settings or, um, you know,
like, hey girlfriend, you know, like that,
things like that. Um, but
we, you know, my, my, uh,
creative creative partner and CEO,
he manwell shall love is in
charge of all edits. And he said,
this is what I want to do.
Um, but I think, you know,
I actually hadn't thought about it in
terms of pedophilia culture that like,
this is literally what I'll be thinking
about for the rest of the day and into
the evening. No, cause I think
that's really fascinating.
I find it easier to correct other people.
And I think that's really interesting,
right? That were too
strong. You know, women, um,
who like red lipstick and you know,
for me,
I have a really hard
time correcting people.
And it's funny cause I think I might've
been on the view of this morning and I
think if someone might have sat and I,
it would never occur to me to say like,
I'm a woman.
Like I couldn't do it.
But the example I give is like my
publicist who's here. Um, you know,
when people say like, she's such
a great girl, you know, for me,
I really am just what I talked about
in the video. I say, um, she's a woman,
you know?
And yeah,
doing it with a smile is just something
that as women sometimes, you know, helps,
you don't always have to do it.
But as I said,
people will hate you less to your
face if you smile. Um, you know,
I think that in terms of correcting
other people, that's really how I do it.
And I think it's important
to realize that we,
although it should be,
I think remedied every single time.
There also has to be some flexibility
in how we approach things. Like,
I sometimes feel like it's my
job to fix the whole world,
but I also have to know that I'm,
I'm part of it.
And I also have to function in
social situations. And sometimes,
and I'm not saying like, oh, um, you know,
everybody wants me to strip naked at
this party. I guess I should, you know,
I'm talking about being flexible in terms
of there are times when I feel like,
you know what,
if I'm this uncomfortable and I know
my convictions and I know how I want to
behave, this may not be the
time to do it, you know?
So I think that's important too,
to give yourself a break and know that
you're not solely responsible. Um,
you have celebrities like me to take a
general bullet for feminists everywhere,
um, and have everyone hate
on me because of it. Um,
but I commend you for correcting it and,
um,
I will try and take some inspiration for
you and try and find creative ways to
correct people. Maybe like a snap
might be good. Like I'm a woman. No,
I didn't say thank you. Yeah.
Not feels good now. Yeah,
it's great. We're done. Yes.
Can you talk about that other video that
you did? The science and religion one?
I thought it was amazing. Oh, thank you.
It was very smart and just like really
beautiful and touching at the same time.
Um, so maybe like what inspired it
and what was the reaction to it?
Yeah, so I'm, I'm a scientist. I'm
trained as a neuroscientist and I'm,
I'm also a person of faith and usually
the people that ask if I have conflict
about that typically are not scientists
and they're not religious. And I,
you know,
I like to point out that sometimes at
no insult to atheists or agnostics,
but sometimes those people
are more fanatical and
religious about being atheist
or agnostic than I am about
being a religious person.
And, um, you know what I,
what I talked about in that video,
and again,
this is something I've been ranting
about, you know, for 15 years, um,
I have never felt conflict. Um, I,
I've never met other orthodox
or religious people, um,
who feel conflict.
I've never met a WHO believes that the
world was literally created in six days.
And then God rested on the set.
Like it's, you know, I, there,
there was a quote that my rabbi
used to quote a lot, you know,
if you think that the, the Torah, you
know, the Old Testament is a science book.
I have better science books on my shelf,
you know, like, um, the, the Torah is a,
is an historical religious,
spiritual, mystical document. Um,
it is not meant to be a science book.
And one of my favorite realizations
that I had is that, um,
we can call it different things,
this, this notion of faith,
but if someone has a belief that
the sun will come up tomorrow,
which I would say we
can mostly all agree on,
to me that's the same faith as me
believing that the universe is divine and
things like the sun coming up happen
and the fact that when the sun comes up,
I come from a religious and ethnic
tradition where we thank God for that
happening.
For a lot of people,
the way that they acknowledge that is
simply to have the alarm go off and get up
and I don't have right to pass judgment
on how people choose to commemorate the
divine act of the sun coming up. So it's
kind of like Neil degrasse Tyson says,
you know,
science is great because you don't have
to believe in it for it to be true.
I kind of feel that way about a mystical
notion of of something divine in the
universe. You know, I don't have to
believe that the sun's going to come up,
it's going to come up. And for me, I
just, I don't feel conflict about that.
Everything I've ever learned
in the scientific world
has made me appreciate the
divinity of the universe. I've never once
said, gosh, the eye is so complicated.
It had to be created by God.
I don't even have to think like that.
The eye is so unbelievable because it
exists in the context of a universe that
that is ruled by physics and chemistry
and all of the things that humans have to
give names to. And really the same applies
for religion and for God. You know,
those are concepts that exist,
whether we name them or not,
it doesn't matter what language you say
it in the fact that we called the number
six,
the number six,
those are all just arbitrary linguistic
classifications for things that
literally exist. Um, so yeah,
like for me it just feels like all is
good in the navy or hood of science and
God,
I like how you also related
that I'm wondering the world
to like internal. Yeah.
I got all emotional recording and like
that was for real. Yeah, it's emotional.
Yeah, no it is. Um, and we do have
time for one or two more questions.
If anyone wants to come see me and my
ex, well, I have five more, but yes,
go ahead. I'll ask the
question. Hi, I'm Nikki.
My question was how do you balance being
a social conservative with being free
liberal? Um, you know,
I think it's funny because this
is something I'm asked a lot,
you know, I think, I'm not trying to
be facetious, I just am, you know,
so the fact that like I don't like to
wear a sleeveless or strapless dresses or
that, um, I prefer that no one's seen me
in a bathing suit. Like, you know, the,
the fact that I make distinctions about
the way I present myself as a woman and
that I find that empowering to me that
is absolutely a no with the fact that we
should not use the death penalty.
Like I'm 100% certain in my mind, um,
that we should not kill people. And um,
you know, for me, like I was raised,
my parents were civil rights
activists and they were actually, um,
they were part of the integration of
public school system here in New York.
And my grandparents were
immigrants. Like, you know,
I was raised as a union support,
like liberal values work for
me all the way around. Um,
as a Jewish person for most
of Jewish history in America,
we have aligned ourselves with the
Democratic party because the principles of
welcoming the stranger and upholding
the fallen and healing the sick, um,
is really part of what I believe
my religious tradition dictates.
But the fact that I don't like the fact
that I don't necessarily want to see
everyone's breasts and butt cheeks in
my life every day, but in Los Angeles,
that's kind of what it's like.
Um, you know, if I had daughters,
I would be a very conservative
parents in terms of dress. Um,
when my children and I go to synagogue,
much as I believe that religion shouldn't
be a thing that children hate because
you have to wear stuffy clothing. I do
believe in a notion of decorum that way.
I'm old fashioned, you know, that's what
people say. Um, I liked domestic things.
I like cooking,
cleaning and sewing.
Anytime I've ever been in
a romantic relationship, my
favorite thing is to like,
what kind of Pie can I make? Like I
just, I, I'm just that kind of person.
I also will make pie that I like
as well. Don't worry. Um, no,
but I think those things get kind of put
in that social conservative sort of box.
Um, but you know, someone pointed
out I was on what show is it?
Was it James Corden? Heather, I
don't know if she's still here. Yeah,
it was a James Corden when I flashed
piers Morgan with my Tatas. Okay. Um,
I was on James Corden and Piers Morgan
was on and he's someone that, you know,
I sometimes agree with but largely don't,
and Susan Surandon had just done like
that in Memoriam thing and piers Morgan
was like super critical and felt like
tweeting about how her breasts shouldn't
have been hanging out.
And this is a, a great,
a great kind of intersection
of my universes where, um,
I was really annoyed at Piers Morgan
because like there are definitely more
important things to think about then
Susan Sarandon's breasts and would,
I would I agree that like if you're doing
a Memoriam and I'm thinking more about
your cleavage then the dead
people. Sure. It's awkward.
But what I did is I turned my back to
the camera and I flashed Piers Morgan.
I was wearing a bra, you
know, there was coverage fine.
Um, but someone pointed out,
you know, that was like an
intersection of my rebellious feminism.
I didn't do it to the camera, you
know, I turned my back. So anyway,
it's still not okay,
I'm sure by a lot of people's standards.
But when I feel like, you
know, how do you combine them?
You just do and there's no
hard and fast rules. You know,
someone pulled up a picture that was
taken, I did a photo shoot in Israel, um,
and I'm wearing a sheer top, sorry,
I'm wearing a sheer top and yes,
you can see cleavage because I'm wearing
whatever. I'm wearing a sheer top,
you know. And people were so quick to say
like, ha ha caught you. I'm like, really?
Is this the world that we live in,
that people are trolling to find pictures
where I violate certain notions of
modesty to prove that I'm, you know, I've
never said that I do anything perfectly.
Um, but I definitely think that the
death penalty should not be allowed.
Thank you. You do a perfect
job of not killing people.
I perfectly don't want people
to die that way. Oh No. Yeah,
yeah. I mean some, sometimes
people die. It happens, but right.
Too soon to talk about death apparently.
Always.
But it also sounds like one
of the differences is that
you're not imposing your
views. You're not saying that like the
laws of the country and to that should be
written on your, I have feelings about
the laws of the country, but yes. Well,
so my laws of the country I think should
opt for more freedom, more acceptance,
more rights, civil rights, human rights,
rights for women, rights for gays,
rights for Trans People. Yeah.
I'm all for that. Um, yes.
And rights for criminals and rights for
murderers because I'm, again, I'm like an,
I'm an old fashioned supporter of those
kinds of rights. Um, and you know,
if I were in, in politics or if I had a
Facebook page with a lot of followers,
I would probably take a lot of stances
and I choose to. Um, but, you know,
I think it's very difficult. There are
certain arenas where I get to say, um,
I'm Vegan. You don't have to be. However,
if you want to talk about
economics and the environment, um,
and our impact on the environment,
then maybe we should have a conversation
about Vegan. We all should, you know,
and I think that's how I feel, you
know, I don't understand. Um, I mean,
I don't want to talk about,
I mean we can't talk about politics.
People want to do,
but I literally don't understand
what's happening really anymore. Um,
and I don't understand a
lot of places where, where,
and how we can affect change. Why I as
a celebrity, why anyone should care.
What I think. Um, and I understand I have
that conflict myself. Why do I do this?
Why do I write, you know, why,
why do I share this on a platform
with millions of people? Um,
and I think I kind of decided like,
this is a new world.
There really aren't rules for what
happens when a celebrity has 2 million
followers and has the power to say,
if you believe in the right, you know,
for women to choose what
to do with their wounds,
you may want to check out planned
parenthood or the ACL ou or the anti
defamation league. You know, like
those are, it's a hard place to be.
And I also don't want people to think
that I do that cavalierly. Yeah.
You can say cavalier be right.
Yeah.
Or in a cavalier fashion that set
skills coming out again. Oh yeah.
I believe.
I think we have one more question.
Yeah.
Thanks so much for being here.
I'm very excited to read
your book and I'm Darcy.
I was curious to know more about
your writing process for this book,
specifically anything about
the writing process, but, um,
I was curious if you talked with the
girls 10 to 18 as you were writing,
um,
and also if there was anything that you
thought about putting in the book that
you didn't end up
a baby wants to know. This
is a good question. So,
um,
you asked about the writing process,
what was the second thing if you talk to,
if I talked with it. So, yeah, I'm, I'm a,
I'm a bad student in this sense
because Jill Santa Paula was,
here are some teen websites that you
should read to know how teens talk.
I'm glad she's not here. I
didn't look at them and um,
honestly I don't want to say I didn't
want to talk to 10 to 18 year old girls.
Um, but in, in my arrogance and
grandiose fashion as a writer,
I really felt like I had this.
Um,
and I know girls in this age
range and my son being 11,
I have friends whose daughters are the
same age. And so I know plenty of girls.
You know, we had a babysitter and
I watched her go from 15 to 18. Um,
but no, I, I'm going to be super honest.
I didn't feel that it was necessary.
And I don't just mean because
like I got a phd and you know,
in neuroscience I get to say
whatever I want. I will say also,
and I give credit to the
women. We had review the book,
we had a school counselor,
a neuropsychologist, um, a pediatrician
and an ob Gyn review the book.
Um,
yeah,
there were things about how I think that
the pill is over prescribed for girls
and that we have a crisis of the treatment
of hormones in young women that was
removed from the book. Just going to
go ahead and say it. Um, yeah. Um,
I mentioned Ricki lake prominently on the
work that she has done to advocate for
natural birth and for,
um,
education about the overprescription
of the pill. And, um, I got some,
where's Anthony Materra? I
got some healthy pushback,
not from Anthony Materra. Um,
I got some healthy pushback about that.
Um,
that surprised me because I know so
many young women who are put on the pill
before their bodies even know
what they're doing hormonally. Um,
especially girls and
underserved populations where
they're not getting followup
care and no one cares
because, sorry. A lot of,
we don't care about poor people
is the message that a lot of, um,
a lot of girls get. Um, so that I
was kind of surprised about. Um,
and in terms of the writing process,
so, you know, um, my, my dad,
bless his memory was a writer. Um, I've
always been a creative writer and I, I,
even though I got a
degree in neuroscience,
I minored in Hebrew and Jewish studies
because it helped keep my GPA up because
I could write a really good essay.
I got an a plus in the
third riot and the Jews,
because I wrote so many great essays
about the third riot. Um, no, but my,
my writing skills are really more in kind
of essay form. Writing a book is very,
very different. And for
this book, I literally,
I took a piece of paper for
every category of our existence,
meaning, you know, um, sex and
dating hormones and puberty.
And then I took postits and I wrote
questions that I would've wanted answered
for each of those categories.
And I wrote them on postits.
So each piece of paper had,
you know, a dozen posts.
And then the way that I started writing
is I started answering those questions.
That's literally the way
the book was written.
I started answering those
questions and I crossed it off.
There's something I'm never like,
I'm a list maker. I'm a postit lover.
So this was a very gratifying experience.
Um, you know, and like pretty Charpie,
different colors for each chapter.
Um, so that's what it was like.
And I carried those pieces
of paper around with me. Um,
I actually finished a screenplay and I
wrote in a very similar fashion that I
did by large note cards,
laid on a hotel bed and I locked myself
in a room and wrote a screenplay. Um,
but yeah, this book was very
similar and I did take time away.
I'm really a person who
loves the writing process.
Like I love to be literally like
I lock myself in a hotel room.
I opened the door only to get French
fries and green salad and instead like,
you know, beers or like a
little wine at dinner. Um,
but that's really how I wrote this book.
And I went away and didn't talk
to anyone and it was great.
And I just sat in a room
and that's when I was told,
you are a writer when you love being in
a room by yourself with a bottle of red
wine and a bowl of pasta and some French
fries and, and the thing. You're right.
You're right. Yeah. No one else. Just me.
Yeah. All right. Well that's all the time.
This was really fun.
Thank you.